when Washington DC for about an hour
that something is a varying speed of
light theory nowadays is a bit like
saying that an animal is not a cat it
doesn't specify much can be an elephant
a zebra or anything and it's the same
with varying speed of life theories
they're really a very large branch of
theories these days in one finger all
united though they're all united in the
fact that do destroy the grammar of
physics of the 20th century because they
contradict with the constant because of
the constancy of the speed of light and
for this reason we have at times been
labeled anarchist physicists someone
even said and i quote we are the sex
pistols of physics I'm not dressed
appropriately I'm sorry about that but I
would like to point out that Einstein
himself proposed the varying speed of
light theory not a widely publicized
fact but in 1911 the great man proposed
the theory which in many ways resembles
ours the motivation was totally
different and in fact in the detail they
are quite different the theories he
considered but it is very important for
Einstein himself the constancy of the
speed of light did not have the dogmatic
nature it has for other people since he
died so it's not that crazy and if you
have good reasons to do so we should
question this principle and this is
exactly what we've done of course
nowadays trying to do something like
that is completely crazy my book really
reads like the diarrhea for the range
physicist because it was a deranged
thing to do was a crazy process all the
dirty laundry is there in that book but
I think we better leave it there and in
this stop what I'll concentrate on
instead is not so much the scientific
process of trying to get your colleagues
to listen to you and not see that you
you used to pay them and that there's no
reason why they should even listen to
you well I'll try to concentrate on is
the scientific reasons that eventually
made them listen to us and I'll talk
about these for the rest of my talk so
there's really two reasons why we
decided to do something this radical and
let me start with cosmology cosmology is
a very strange science is a science
which asks
questions such as where did universe
came from or does anything ever change
in the universe is everything always the
same or is there evolution in the
universe how old is the world or is the
world eternal will there be a name for
the universe
so these kinds of questions are often
asked by kids very seriously I don't
know if you've had this experience kids
love asking these questions and less
seriously they've been asked by
philosophers and within the context of
religion even less seriously though they
have been asked by physicists more
recently and it is a bit surprising
indeed that this kind of questions can
be seen as scientific questions as
something you can actually address from
the point of view of the every physicist
the same way that you can describe a
bridge or a car or a cell phone and you
basically just look at the whole
universe and you try to answer these
questions I should say that it's really
fascinating this has become part of
theoretical physics but also part of
experimental physics these questions
nowadays can be addressed by
observations it's not as if you can go
into the experiment because the
experiment was only done once of course
you cannot go out and and create a big
banner but you can look up at the sky
and try to see in what is left from the
universe the smoking gun for your
theories and the amazing thing is that
the smoking gun is extremely well hidden
and it took a long time to find it it
actually caused Einstein to do one of
the worst errors in his career and it's
a very difficult branch of physics
cosmology but it's becoming an
experimental science these days when you
look at when you look up at the sky
which is what you should look up to try
and find some model of observational
cosmology if you're in England you'd
only see clouds of course but if you but
if you are in a more Clement climate you
are actually see stars and all kinds of
things beautiful things in the sky and
you know that it would be stupid to do
what an Englishman probably would do
which is create a model of the universe
based on clouds you know that's a detail
the clouds are moving around so you
might think the universe is changing but
you know this is really an irrelevant
and when you look at sufficiently big
you see all these things that don't
really move around with respect to
themselves so the temptation is to pause
to create a model of the universe which
is static where nothing ever changes the
men that destroyed this point of view
was this guy Edwin Hubble is an American
astronomer he actually is not an
astronomer is a lawyer who decided to
send law to hell and look at the sky for
the rest of his life I make this joke
with some trepidation in Washington but
I should say it with credit that it was
very good it was a lawyer and not a
professional astronomer because these
made him do very unusual observations
observations people did not consider to
be the normal way of looking at the sky
so it specifically amounted this
telescope on a dome which rotated
exactly so as to counter the rotation of
the earth so what you could do with this
is point your telescope to the same
point in the sky for very long periods
and it is amazing because what does this
do for you is that not only you can see
very small things because your telescope
amplifies things magnifies things but
you can see very fine things if you put
a photographic plate on the other side
of the telescope and you wait six hours
you can also see very very fine things
not only very small things and this is
what came out is this amazing thing the
world of galaxies and the galaxies are
nothing but collections of stars
billions and billions of stars swirling
around this very bright guy in the
middle and the picture that comes out is
that astronomers and cosmologists have
been looking at clouds all along the
stars you see in the sky from the point
of view of the universe is like the
clouds in this English cosmology I
pointed out earlier on these stars are
really relevant details they're nothing
but components of one galaxy the Milky
Way is one of many galaxies such as this
one and you have to think big
you have to look big before you start
making any sense out of cosmology so the
amazing thing is that once you look at
with the right perspective the universe
is expanding it's not static at all
galaxies are moving away from each other
or to be more precise space is being
created in between them there's this
phenomena of creation of space in
between the galaxies kind of a dream for
any urban architect you actually have
space being created but it's one of the
conclusions of relativity the space is
dynamic and what you see in the universe
is exactly that process the dynamic
process of creation of space so the
universe is evolving is getting diluted
is getting colder and conversely the
very young universe must have been very
hot and if you actually go and look at
things extrapolate to the beginning you
find universe must have popped out of a
very very hot phase the Big Bang so the
big conclusion of Hubble is that look at
the right elements it's the difference
between a forest in the tree you really
want to make a model for the forest so
don't look at leaves don't look at the
branches of the tree look at trees as a
collection try to make a model of the
universe with the right scale and what
comes out is two things
there's evolution in the universe the
universe is changing and time is
expanding and more importantly there is
a beginning for the universe there's a
moment of creation called the Big Bang
so this was the world revealed by Hubble
and I should say immediately this is an
incredibly successful model of the
universe I could spend hours here
telling you about the successes of this
theory it predicted many things that
were indeed observed indeed I spend
hours lecturing on these so it's not as
if I don't know about the successes when
I'm now going to tell you that there are
problems as well so there are many many
problems but there are many many
successes as a physicist we concentrate
on the problems because we want to do
something new success is our old story
and the varying speed of light theory is
really something that hinges upon one of
these problems it's called a horizon
problem it's not the main problem in
modern cosmology is about 10 of them
but it is the tip of the iceberg for all
the other problems and I shall
concentrate on this one because it's
also the simplest one to describe your
horizon problem is a very embarrassing
thing about the Big Bang Theory and it's
the fact that you have this universe
which displays a unity and nearly
pantheistic unity which it has no right
to have within the context of the Big
Bang Theory you look at universe
everywhere every corner of the universe
is exactly the same type of galaxies
it's expanding exactly the same way at
the same rate it has the same
temperature it looks like a photocopy of
all the other regions it's exactly the
same everywhere
it's very homogeneous and the problem is
that according to the Big Bang Theory
there's no mechanism that can explain
why this is so you might think that this
is so because everything was in contact
at the Big Bang why are things the same
well if you have coffee and milk you put
milk inside coffee you wait a bit it
kind of gets the same everywhere you
steer it it gets the same everywhere you
put objects in contact they acquire the
same temperature so contact is the thing
that could have explained this unity of
the universe and in fact what the Big
Bang Theory gives you is a very artistic
start for the universe the universe
which is totally fragmented into regions
that don't know about each other
and this is the horizon problem let me
explain exactly how this happens so any
universe in which the speed of light is
a speed limit in which there is an age
for the universe as an effect called
horizon effect which means there's
always a distance beyond which you can't
see so it looks like there is an edge of
space there's a region which really
limits basically how much you can see of
the universe and the argument goes as
follows first of all when you look far
away what you see is really easy you're
looking at things in the past if you
look at the galaxy which is a billion
light years away from you you're looking
at this galaxy a billion years ago it
emitted this light the light came
towards you spent a billion years
traveling so you're seeing a photograph
of this galaxy a long time ago so for
this reason because molar
is a much better of new cosmologists
than archeologists and basically we have
this ability to see the past but the
problem is that I can only see as far as
I am old there's always going to be a
distance beyond which I can't see
because there haven't been time since
the Big Bang for light to travel towards
us so there is this kind of limitation
to how much I can see because of the
fact that universe has a birthday a
birthdate and the fact that there is a
limit to the speed of light the problem
is not so much that the reason arise and
the problem is that the anger I am the
less I can see so some of you will
actually like this the older you get the
more you see the younger you are the
more limited you get and this is what I
mean by a very artistic start of the
universe the universe is fragmented to
these tiny regions they learn about each
other the completely self-absorbed they
haven't seen the address and yet they
share all these properties they're very
homogeneous they have exactly the same
genetic code if you want and somehow we
cannot explain that because they are out
of contact so this is really the origin
of the horizon problem this is really
the thing that causes all the other
problems in cosmology is the fact that
universe does not want to have this
unity which we observe it's completely
fragmented and why is that well it's
because light with a speed limit and
universe as an age and this is of course
the thing that prompted me to ask is new
physics lurking around the corner is
this an indication for new physics
already so you can already see the VSL
temptation at this point the varying
speed of light temptation is with us a
scene is begging to be committed at this
point you know immediately that if you
allowed light to travel much faster in
the beginning if you could circulate
information much faster you could
actually bring the whole universe
together it could create a unified
universe in which everything is actually
in contact at the beginning at the Big
Bang this was exactly the revelation I
had it took a long time to turn this
into a proper physical theory and much
has been made of the fact that I had the
terrible hangover when I had this
revelation
it was after a very big party and my
mind could not have been further away
from physics but it's maybe because I
had the guard down you know I wasn't
thinking my god the speed of light has
to be constant and somehow I just notice
it was possible to solve all these
painting problems these terrible
problems in cosmology by allowing light
to be much faster in the early universe
so having an end over is not terribly
respectable so in order to infuse some
respectability into this talk let me
tell you other things that were in my
mind at the time especially while I was
doing my PhD she's a poet from Paul
Dirac in 1968 which I find very
inspirational and maybe this is the
thing that prompted me to do something
so mad
in 1968 Paul Dirac said and I'm going to
read this for you one field of work in
which there has been too much
speculation is cosmology there are very
few hard facts to go on but theoretical
workers have been busy constructing
various models for the universe based on
any assumptions that they fancy these
models are probably all wrong
Dirac was extremely rude it is usually
assumed that the laws of nature have
always been the same as they are now
there is no justification for this the
laws may be changing and in particular
quantities which are considered to be
constants of nature brackets speed of
light is one possibility may be varying
with cosmological time such variations
would completely upset model makers so I
should tell you that this is extremely
unfair this was 1968 okay and since then
there's quite a few hard facts to base
cosmology upon but none of them
penetrates the life of the universe
before one second of age and I could
explain it the reasons we actually have
a good handle on what universe was doing
all the way down in a childhood
everything all the way back to one
second before one second we haven't got
a clue
and everything Dirac said is applicable
to that period in life of the universe
the universe could have been doing
anything before one second of age and it
is a very big extrapolation to say that
the laws of physics we measure now in
the laboratory are the same in these
extreme conditions at the Big Bang when
the universe was so hot
and conditions are so totally out of
anything we have experienced
specifically what Dirac is really saying
is this physics change in time we know
that universe changes in time now you
know if you look at the Stars you have
this impression universe is static but
if you look at the galaxies you really
think the universe is more like the
clouds you see in the sky it's changing
there is evolution the ingredients are
changing the universe is getting diluted
could it be that not only the content of
the universe is evolving in time but the
laws that govern this matter are
evolving in time and you see something
which is very important in the context
of a static universe you would not make
any sense to question that the laws are
changing in time in the context of a Big
Bang Theory it makes all the sense and
this is really the thing that motivated
me to to propose a varying speed of
light theory Dirac himself never went
this far you consider other constants of
nature but a possibility certainly a
varying speed of light so basically what
we find is that cosmology is really
telling you two things you have to be
careful if you're going to consider a
varying speed of light theory that your
changes do not happen significantly
after one second because we know that we
know that the speed of light is not
varying widely recently so any theory
you have you can have very big changes
before one second during the Big Bang
but after one second you better make
sure that you only have a residual
variations in the speed of light but
even then what you find is that you can
actually solve the horizon problem you
can bring the whole universe into
contact and more importantly you can
solve all the other cosmological
problems which are indeed derived from
the horizon problem remember I told you
was the tip of the iceberg there were
many other things and you can solve them
too so I should pause here and deep
briefly into the dirty and aware of
laundry of kind of physics sociology of
horrible things that happen I should
tell you that there was there are also
some sociological reasons why we came up
with this theory and that's to do with
the
there is another way to solve these
problems and that's a theory proposed by
Alan Guth in the 1980s called inflation
the theory of inflation is somewhat
orthogonal from varying speed of light
theories it does not change the physics
but it proposes a different ingredient
for the early universe and the fact that
I was looking at alternatives to
inflation reflects the big Atlantic
divided between England English physics
and us physics there's some kind of
belief in the UK that any any time an
American physicist proposes something
that cannot be right and I heard
horrible things said about the theory of
inflation I heard things like the
statement that inflation is an American
PR success that it's not really a
physical theory because you cannot go
and test it it's something that only
happens in the early universe but I
always felt the English were a bit
unfair because they did not have an
alternative you're just whining about
American saving than these and not
actually presenting an alternative so I
don't subscribe to these Shelvey listing
views I'm not English and Portuguese but
it's undoubtedly true that I was under a
lot of peer pressure at the time to come
up with a theory which was not inflation
and to my mind the reason why in any
case you should come up with a different
theory is that you don't know how well
the theory is doing until we have a
competitor you need to have a competitor
and then it laid experimental data and
then you need to be able to actually
measure how well these two theories do
against the data to actually rule out
one or take the other so in a way this
feels a bit strange I propose this fear
it's a competitor to inflation it's
going to be nature that decides at the
end of the day this experiment it's
going to decide I do feel like it's like
two guys fighting for the same
girlfriend it's a very strange feeling
but at the end of the day it's the
objectivity of experiment that will
decide and let me tell you that the main
difference between inflation and varying
speed of light theories is exactly that
inflation doesn't change the foundations
of physics doesn't leave any trace later
on directly and as a result
you basically are safe that you cannot
predict anything in the sky that will
rule it out whereas we are much you know
really in danger of being ruled out but
it that means also that might be some
evidence for varying speed of light
theories so let me present the evidence
and this was not something we were
banking on when we proposed the theory
this was a surprise some people have
been trying to measure the speed of
light in the past or at least one of the
ways of interpreting what they're doing
is that way so there's a group of
astronomers and led by John Webb we have
been looking at this spectrum of light
when it flashes through clouds and when
that happens you find these small lines
appearing which represents frequencies
or colors which have been absorbed by
the cloud and this represents nothing
but the different energy levels inside
the atoms of these clouds and the
interesting thing is that this lines
subdivide into many many small lines
which are all blended together and if
you have accurate enough experiment you
can actually resolve this pleating and
this splitting allows you to measure the
speed of light and what you've been
doing is looking at these lights as
these lines formed very far away you're
looking at quasars quasars are billions
and billions of light years away from us
and they have cloudy they've got
basically all this cloud all these
clouds in front and they form all these
lines but these lines have been formed
billions of years ago
so you're basically looking at lines
formed in the past and you're basically
measuring the speed of light in the past
when you do this and this is the result
surprise they find that a few billions
of years ago the speed of light was
indeed slightly higher this is actually
the quantity they measure there's a
speed of light factor in there and they
find that a few billions of years ago
it's basically the fifth decimal that's
changing this is not the Big Bang she's
a few billions of years ago you'd have
to go like off the scale on the other
side to actually measure the big big
change in the speed of light we predict
we do predict a residual at very late
times and this is exactly what has been
observed so this is the statistically
she's very sick
if you can't pee percent iams ask what's
the probability what's the significance
of this
that's 99.999% it's very high but these
observations are very very delicate so I
wouldn't start investing on VSL and take
all my money out of relativity yet but
it does look like there is some
indication the speed of light was indeed
varying in the past so let me move on to
the final aspect looking at this data
you might think that we're in trouble
relativity is in trouble we are now
approaching a very big 100th birthday
2005 is going to be the 100th birthday
of special relativity the question is
are we going to spoil the party with
this data and I'd like to point out this
is not at all the case this is actually
the opposite this could actually be a
realization of Feinstein's dying dream
and this is the picture I like most
about his dying dream of Einstein it's a
picture of Einstein's office as he left
it when he died and you see all these
scribblings around here and the thing it
was looking for at the time he died is
called the grand unified theory he was
looking for a principle which could
unify everything electricity magnetism
gravity the nuclear force is everything
and there one single force one single
principle and it is our greatest failure
he died without discovering what this
final theory was and we don't know what
his final theory is at all these days
and I have to confess I found myself
actually trying to see what he was
writing on the blackboard and there's
nothing there I'm afraid it's actually
very boring this is a very difficult
problem in physics you have to have
worked on this problem to actually know
how hard it is if you want to get 100%
failure rate in a physics exam just set
it as a problem it is guaranteed and
it's not just a physics exam it may
spend years of your life and people have
spent lifetimes trying to solve this
problem without actually getting
anywhere it's an extremely difficult
problem
and what I'm about to do now is give you
my personal view on this problem so to
my mind the problem is that unification
means to quantize space and time and the
argument is a bit complex but let me go
through it is basically you only get the
final result if you don't understand it
but it's actually not very complicated
but basically you trying to get a
unification between gravity and other
forces of nature and gravity is a
property of space-time according to the
theory of relativity is the curvature of
space-time space-time as dynamics it can
appear it can disappear it can curve we
can warp we can do all kinds of crazy
things and it's debt dynamics of space
and time that describes gravity and the
problem you have is that other forces of
nature
for instance electromagnetism are
quantized by which I mean they can in
what I may call in the great sense of
the word atoms in smallest quantities
that cannot be divided any further
for instance the atom of the
electromagnetic force is the photon so
you see what the problem is if you try
to unify electromagnetism and the other
forces of nature with gravity you have
to quantize gravity but gravity is a
property of space and time so you have
to quantize space and time which means a
crazy thing it means that time is not
this continuum you might think it is it
actually comes in drops at time is a bit
like a necklace with small small beads
and there are atoms of time their
instance with finite duration which
represent the smallest indivisible
amount of time and likewise space is not
two continuum you might think it is it's
granular and this is exactly the kind of
picture you have to come up with to
quantize gravity and therefore to
achieve something which has a chance to
be unified with the other forces of
nature which are already quantized we
know that for a fact
so these atoms of space and time are
called the Planck length and the Planck
time we know they're very small we've
never seen them but this is the thing
we're looking for a theory which
contains atoms of space and time
so this is my impression why everything
has failed so far it is my impression my
friendly small and we've been working on
this for a long time every time you try
to do something like quantizing gravity
looks very simple everything collapses
it's complete disaster
you get infinities everywhere you get
nonsense it's complete disaster
and if you if something doesn't work at
least you should know why it doesn't
work and I think we now know why
everything has failed so to our mind the
problem is you might ask what kind of
objects suffer from these effects of
quantum gravity quantized space and time
and you might think that well something
which is much larger than LP than the
Planck length than the atoms of space
will be subject to classical gravity to
the usual theory whereas something which
is smaller than this quantity or
comparable to this quantity will finally
understand that space is full of
potholes and will therefore be affected
by these new effects of quantum gravity
so you have one object and you now
basically have this criterion for
deciding whether this is a classical or
a quantum gravity object and this is the
problem sneakily you find that
relativity introduces a contradiction
you know that length contraction is one
of the predictions of the theory of
relativity based on a constant speed of
light and what you find is you've got
this object and it could be that some
observers moving fast enough seed shrank
below this atom of space whereas other
other observers are not moving fast
enough with respect to it I would see it
much larger so this is the contradiction
you basically have different observers
looking at the same object one things we
need the final theory the other one
things we don't need the final theory we
have a contradiction immediately so what
we need really is some kind of
modification of relativity somehow you
need a theory where length contraction
switches off at small distances and you
know that length contraction is
something that comes like time dilation
comes from the fact that I want to have
the speed of light to be the same for
everyone
instead what you should require is for
these atoms of space and time to be the
same for everyone
there should be a shift in absolute
between the speed of light and the plank
the atoms of space and time so what we
need really
we found something which resembles an
energy or a length dependent speed of
light which is equivalent to the thing I
told you earlier they are theories in
which the speed of light is color
dependent that's the kind of theory we
found where this paradox does not arise
the amazing thing is that the universe
came to our help there is again some
observational evidence for these crazy
theories in which you have a varying
speed of light and you can have
invariant atoms of space and time
your provisional evidence I want to tell
you about is this thing called
ultra-high energy cosmic rays so we are
constantly being bombarded by the
universe we are these cosmic rays coming
from explosions of stars even bigger
explosions they'll release all these
particles of very high energy they can
throughout the universe and they're
actually hitting this room I told it all
the time we don't feel it but they're
around the earth if you put the detector
you will actually see these particles
and for a long time it had been
predicted that there should be a cut off
very sharp cut off in the energies of
this cosmic rays and you can actually
prove this using basic laws of
relativity that the true not because
McRae's above a given critical energy
and what was found was exactly that they
are very very high-energy cosmic rays
this is quite a crazy thing and people
have speculated for a long time that
special relativity probably breaks down
it is very high energies what we found
was nothing but that we could explain
this high-energy cosmic rays we could
raise the threshold at which you
shouldn't see anything and explain is
crazy very high energetic particles
which have indeed been observed so I
think I'm going to cut this short here
I'm going to encourage questions I'm
sure you left some of them let me just
summarize the reasons to be proud I told
you about the motivations for doing
something this mad well maybe it's not
that mad if you're not a physicist you
don't care really it's to be very honest
you have to be a professional physicist
to know that it really is a crazy thing
to
you and your colleagues like staring
hysterically at you first time I say
these people really laughed hysterically
you're on the floor okay and I hope I
have at least explained some reasons in
cosmology why it's really good idea to
have a much faster light in the early
universe you're encouraging circulation
of information in the Big Bang at the
moment of creation of the universe and
therefore you can actually omajin eyes
the universe can create these unity at
all told you about I didn't mention many
other problems but there are many other
problems that follow directly from this
one and we can explain them crazily
enough
Einstein's final dream of a unified
theory so called quantum gravity will be
part of it and we may need to actually
do something this dramatic to get the
consistent theory of quantum gravity and
more importantly there may be some
relation between things
observers have been looking at for the
past few years and these theories I
mentioned spectral lines they have these
observations which could be measurements
of speed of light several billion years
ago and they do have this imprint and
the high-energy cosmic rays that could
be another smoking gun for this theory
thank you very much
[Applause]
I think you have to go to the and it's a
plane I'm sorry but could you outline
the most important experiment you will
be doing the next coming years to test
your theory mmm-hmm so as I said this
these observations are very
controversial and you need to do more of
the same before anything else you should
do more observations of spectral lines
from very far away another way of
proving these theories to look not so
much far away but near very massive
objects if you have variations in the
speed of light in time
you must have variations in the speed of
light in space as well near very massive
objects so if you look at the spectral
lines at these lines at these dark lines
from in the surface of stars you should
be able to see the same kind of effect
if accepted you need something more
massive than a star you need something
like a black hole maybe an accretion
disk around a black hole it's the kind
of observations we're looking for how is
the homogeneity problem solved by a
faster speed of light during the first
second of the universe okay so I only
told you you needed something like that
12 an in order to bypass a no-go theorem
so if the speed of light is a constant
and then you have this arising effect
and you cannot imagine eyes the universe
if it's much faster you open up the
horizon because the distance travelled
by light since the beginning becomes
much larger much larger now this does
not explain why things should become
homogeneous it only tells you that there
is no longer a no-go theorem for a
process that organizes everything so the
theory we have is actually uses formal
processes whenever you put a hot and a
cold body together they get the same
temperature there's a flow of heat as
thermal currents that ensure everything
is the same temperature if you actually
open up your aizen's with faster light
then you can actually allow these
thermal currents to spread much much
further and therefore you can imagine
eyes the whole universe
in some of your other papers which I've
read that I found on the internet you
talked also about the variation of G and
alpha does this enhance support or
change in any way your variables speed
of light Theory's so physicists are
complete turrets we just use all the
theories and we play with them all and
and it is - we have work on all these
theories and so in some of them you have
varying gravitational constant other
ones you have varying electric charge
other ones you can even have varying
Planck constant as well so all of these
- what we consider them all because we
don't know which one is right so what
we're doing is get all these theories
together work on them all find the
observationally diction's they all have
and they different and then let nature
let the observations decide which one is
right or wrong a second question with
modern string theory there's lots of
talk of more than three physical
dimensions and I'm not speaking of space
and time will multi dimensions if such
exists enhance again your theories or so
one of them and that's a very good
question one of the implementations of a
varying speed of light is exactly with
extra dimensions it could be that we
live in a wire world there's extra
dimensions the three dimensions we see
at the length of the wire and everything
else is just curled around you know in a
very small small radius therefore we
cannot see the extra dimensions so we
could be that light doesn't go straight
along the wire it could go like it as a
helix and if light goes as a helix with
constant speed then the projected speed
along the three dimensions we see could
be varying depends on the angle of your
helix so they are indeed theories of
lecture dimensions which have a varying
speed of light as observed on our
3-dimensional world there's no one else
I have one further question and yeah go
for it at one time we didn't think we
could go faster than Mach 1 due to
thrust and so forth do you feel that
perhaps someday we will actually be able
to travel maybe not as humans but even
messages or things faster than
current estimate of the upper band the
shock you have to be you have to be very
careful about going faster than light
because you break the principle of
causality you have this problem that you
know the effect would come before the
cause and you have all kinds of crazy
things you know you could invert the
order of time the sequence of time you
could kill your grandmother and see what
happens this kind of things
the problem is with all these principles
refer to what we call micro causality
you should not move faster than light
locally it could be that light the speed
of light varies from place to place and
therefore you could move slower than the
speed of light locally and still much
faster than the speed of light here so
in particularly consider these objects
called cosmic strings and we found that
they have the property the speed of
light increases very sharply near them
so in these objects you could actually
move slower than light along the string
but that's the local speed of light and
that could be that slower than light
there could be much faster than light
here and therefore it could actually
break the barrier literally the barrier
of the speed of light thank you very
much
yeah
have you been able to hypothesize a
generation mechanism to generate the
variable speed of life good so I decided
to take this slide out of my
presentation but it's the answer so as I
said at the beginning there's a vesl
nowadays is really an umbrella term
there's many different theories and
right from the start we add one
mechanism and so in fact this comes from
a long time ago and this guy DK in
Princeton they said that maybe the
constants of nature are not constant at
all the values of fields so we
introduced the field that represented
the gravitational constant and this
field is dynamical and you can do the
same thing with the speed of light can
be a field and as universe expands and
dilute these field changes and therefore
the speed of light changes this was our
mechanism but as many address so I
pointed out that carry fear is in which
the speed of light is energy dependent
in fact you need that property to have a
consistent quantum gravity theory so as
the universe gets hotter speed of light
gets higher another one was someone
asked me about extra dimensions that's
another way of implementing it it could
be that the speed of light and the speed
of gravity are not the same in the early
universe they converge only recently so
there's some talk about it's been
measured the speed of gravity in the
speed of light are the same that could
be a very recent phenomenon and it could
be that the speed of light was much
larger than the speed of gravity in the
very early universe and many other
things have a big etc here because after
we proposed these initial theories
there's actually been quite a lot of
interest in the community and people
have proposed many different theories
[Music]
it's a very knowing question so the
theory of inflation is as a big problem
she's the graceful exit because it
postulates a new field the inflaton
field which causes inflation solves all
these problems but then you have to get
rid of the field somehow and this is the
graceful exit you want to get rid of
inflation gracefully and it's not very
graceful basically it's very difficult
to solve the problem we don't have an
extra field this is just normal
radiation normal stuff in the universe
so we don't you don't need to change
gears okay you don't need to change the
population of the universe you only
dinosaurs disappear okay so you have a
situation in which there is not even a
problem of graceful exit we have other
problems okay no that's not one of them
is it possible that instead of
quantizing gravity you come up with a
continuous theory to describe the other
forces continues theory describing well
other forces well yes that's a big
that's a big question no one has been
able to do that you essentially do
question in quantum mechanics and the
quantization of electromagnetism when
you ask that question and that's of
course what Einstein was working on at
the time that blackboard I showed it was
an attempt to circumvent quantum
mechanics and many other things and he
was working on this theory called
non-symmetric theory of gravity and of
course that's a possibility no one has
been able to do that quantum mechanics
is really tough it's really bison
reality it's really by some experiment
literally your cell phone is what uses
quantum mechanics and so but it could be
that quantum mechanics is not from the
Manville but there's no indication for
that so far it's a possibility you're
quite right
mmm-hmm and it's going to be a hard fish
can you say a few words about how VSL
solves cosmological constant Romney's
question so I bypassed many many of
these problems and that I did may be
mentioned here mayor that's like so the
cosmological constant problem app is
just start by describing what it is when
Einstein proposed this model of the
universe called the static universe
which you call this biggest blunder okay
he needed to postulate that the vacuum
energy was not zero
she's crazy basically saying nothing is
energy and the energy of the vacuum is
of course the cosmological constant is a
constant which was introduced to make
the universe static so it's called
cosmological now this thing is really
weird if the vacuum is some energy it
does not get diluted
as the universe expands and what it
means is that if you have the slightest
trace of vacuum energy it very quickly
comes to dominate the universe because
everything else is getting diluted this
guy isn't so this guy dominates
everything so it's an instability the
universe wants to be dominated by the
vacuum and it's called the cosmological
constant problem how does VSL solve the
problem it's a tricky one but
essentially if the speed of light is not
a constant neither is the cosmological
constant nothing is a constant the speed
of light is not a constant because it's
ingrained in everything and the energy
in the vacuum then becomes dependent on
the speed of light and as the speed of
light drops you get rid of this vacuum
energy as far as I'm aware it's the only
mechanism in which you can get rid of
vacuum energy it's varying speed of
light series so you have a chance of
preventing the universe from becoming
dominated by the cosmological constant
if the speed of light varies
dark energy so in this way you get rid
of the cosmological constant part two we
are actually surrounded by cosmological
constant the guys who have been
observing the way the universe is
expanding
I found that universe is accelerating
and nothing well not nothing but the
simplest way to explain that is saying
there is actually non vanishing
cosmological constant around at the
moment so we have this problem not only
you have to get rid of this guy but you
cannot get rid of it completely because
it's around now okay so you have to make
sure it was sub dominant during most of
the life of the universe but very
recently well it's coming up again is
resurfacing so we managed to find a
model where this happens and you have to
have a theory in which the cosmological
constant when it dominates causes
changes in the speed of light and when
it does it then you get rid of the
cosmological constant and you put all
this energy into matter and it caused a
big bang
so in these theories you have basically
seesaw between you know you get rid of
the cosmological constant big bang no
cosmological constant constant speed of
light more or less for you know 15
billion years then the cosmological
constant stays underneath because it's
not being suppressed anymore once the
speed of light is a constant and then
resurfaces that's what we see now so
this actually answers the other question
which is what's the future of the
universe is it going to be dominated by
the cosmological constant well in this
theory now it's going to cause a big
change in the speed of light again in
the next few billion years and it's
going to cause a new Big Bang so I don't
know if this makes you feel better about
this
but I never wrote a paper on the future
of the universe okay but but the
dynamics is basically this one so we can
explain the current acceleration of the
universe as well curiosity when the
universe starts accelerating it's about
the same time when you start seeing
these variations in alpha so there is a
coincidence you can actually with this
theory can explain two plots of that
totally independent with the same theory
yeah yes residual variations so I said
at the bank at the moment of the Big
Bang to solve all these various problems
you need to add to the speed of light
about 64 zeroes they exchanged but then
what you need to do is make sure that
your theory because you don't want to
conflict with experiment so this happens
in the very extreme moments of the Big
Bang and then you need to make sure that
by the time you reach one second is not
very very much anymore and the
observations you make of course you can
never switch it off completely because
you varied so much you can never switch
it off completely later on then the
predictions we make is that when
universe is not one second all but like
three billion years old or five billion
years old then the variations are about
10 to the minus 5 so the fifth decimal
place which is what has been saying so
we're talking about very different
periods in the life of the universe
there's the Big Bang moment and that's
really well before one second and then
you can have huge changes in the speed
of light and then there's the you know
post one second few billion years of age
and be careful we cannot be much as we
like fifth decimal place yeah
what is VSL say about the singularities
are you talking about black hole
singularities or about the universe
singularity both Modi aster is a bit
different actually you remove the
singularity you remove the singularity
of a black hole this was a horrible
thing I mean so we had this theory and
then you know you have your baby theory
there and you can solve any problem
which has been solving relativity so I
went off okay let me solve a black hole
Winnie's theory and you ask you remember
the order I had when I noticed that the
speed of light goes to zero on the
horizon of a black hole she's an
incredible result you basically saying
because the speed of light is still the
speed limit everything stops as things
try to penetrate your eyes and of a
black hole
now the singularity is well inside the
horizon is in the middle of the black
hole so you're basically stating that
the singularity is no longer physical it
reflects a bit of space-time that's not
accessible to anyone because it's
covered by a surface of zero speed of
light around it so in a way you do
remove the singularity problem you just
get rid of a black hole is more like a
hole in space not just a black hole we
cannot get in there so the singularity
is no longer physical
yeah we're here polish but they've been
published in Physical Review mainly and
and some of them have been published in
Physics Letters B in classical and
quantum gravity if you want to read them
it's it's all published but I would
advise you to read to read them on the
archives we use disaster OPH archives
they're all there
- monies point LK cosmological here I
don't think my basis of knowledge is
good enough I never understood you from
basic fingers wide I just I believed
that the speed of light had be constant
seems to me he just made that up to make
other things work we can solve certain
sources the second question is other
practical ramifications if the speed of
light varies does that change anything
in our day to day older equals
mc-squared things like batteries if you
talk about a variation it is so broad in
fact yeah I mean I don't think it's
going to improve your mobile phone
having the variant a varying speed of
light is not gonna have technological
implications in the nearest future
but it's the same when Einstein proposed
relativity no one could guess the
implications of relativity and they were
pretty massive so it was like all pencil
and paper and thinking and look at what
happens since so whenever you asked
about you know implications for our
everyday life and you know technology we
just don't know it's very early days
regarding your first question what I can
say is that Einstein had very good
reasons for proposing a constant speed
of light and people had actually
measured that the motion of the earth
did not affect the speed of light and
this is this basically pictorially I
show you these cars moving past this
light ray that's nothing but kind of a
cartoon version of what had been
observed at a time so Einstein wasn't
still stupid come on I mean it was it
was a big guy it was big you know a very
clever intelligent guy it did what had
to be done given the data and he was a
very radical thing but you know
do anything theories of multiverse No so
the multiverse I don't know what you
mean by multiverse can you define
multiverse
yeah well which ones multiple universes
now accepted theory well the word
multiverse can mean many things I mean
I'm I'm not trying to harass you by
asking the question it is actually a
very undefined concept so the the
multiverse idea for instance exists in
quantum mechanics I mean every time you
have many possibilities and you have
Schrodinger's cat dead and alive you
just say the universe split into two and
of course we have nothing to say about
that and the results of this idea which
came out of inflation that there's not
one universe but there's like
proliferation of universes all over the
place and going back to this question
about the cosmological constant that you
can have new big banks and every time
you get dominated by the cosmological
constant you produce a big bang then we
do have a multiverse I mean our Big Bang
is one of many in the past in the future
elsewhere so there is a multiverse but
this is not the kind of thing you can
prove you cannot go into the next
universe knock on the door and say is
there a universe up there of course you
can't do that you know it's predicted by
these theories by inflation by varying
speed of light theories but what you
test from the theories is never anything
that resembles the existence of
multiverses we are stuck in this one
come on come
[Music]
shortly after it was discovered that the
universe are you our universe which i
think is an infinite column was it was
accelerating Yellen proposes
accelerating not because it was pushing
the because it was pulled now if
something is not outside of our universe
is possible that it's full and if it's
big full the pull may not be uniform you
farmer David our universe and their
uncertain people have looked for that
and sometimes they find it sometimes
they know but you know the accuracy of
these looking
to learn about the tension that default
so when you say pool is it possible that
the university annex panic was pushed by
dark energy but because it's cold but
other things in the multiverse in the
cosmos outside you mean someone in the
other universe pulling us well it's I
know I know it's there don't say someone
yeah are you sure sure sure sure
um spirit well the spirit may be you
I think consider the universe is
infinite so when I say is fear I think
the university are carolien finished yet
you would look at many-body problem like
this like polarization you would take a
spirit inside of a body and then you
would look you
look at the problem from inside this is
Alex Kyle sphere engine abstraction we
live inside of something bigger than
ourselves and this is very different
from a many body problem this is it's
the whole body problem it's everything
problem basically and the only way to
kind of make things interact that we
know of is gravity so things interact by
gravity not by mechanical forces or
anything like that and it our universal
cosmos which kept privacy
patiently create hard you mean a nice
all trapeze different direct okay yeah
sure I mean as long as you have a
prediction fine I mean that's a physical
theory if you don't have a prediction
it's not a physical theory if you have a
prediction if you say that you know you
have so we can be tested we move the
expansion to be isotropic we do observe
the expansion to be very isotropic
notice more look at the cosmic radiation
the cosmic radiation is very isotropic
where does the cosmic radiation fit
inside your picture we are actually
looking at horizons which are about the
size of the moon when we look at the
cosmic radiation so we are certainly did
certainly don't have anything around
there's lots of them and the all kind of
uniform they don't know about each other
this fear is a conceptual sphere its
axis basically a physical effect to base
it's an optical effect the universe is
actually very imagined isn't very large
and there's nothing outside it in that
sense
I should have not what is a matter of
I've heard someone say the fundamental
physical toxins change with time I was
discussed now with a colleague of mine
who's a PhD engineer as well as that
work dr. rabbi now
he reckons thought how Orthodox
religions reconciled their date their
dating system like in Judea seems like
5859 hundreds of people sort with things
like carbon-14 dating and other things
which tell us the ATR is four billion
years and so forth and so on and the
answer was another invisible process and
exchange I can see coming
should I follow her legends
so do you know about this thing called
the Oklo natural reactor the Oklo
natural reactor and so this happens in
Gabon in Africa and there was like a
nuclear explosion but something which
looks like a nuclear power station you
know going critical and and they
discover this is basically in the inner
mine in a uranium mine and if thought oh
my god is his terror is getting uranium
out of this place and it isn't it's
something that happened four billion
years ago there was a natural reactor it
was just it's a crazy thing but the way
the way the various shells and various
layers of uranium piled up created just
the right configuration for a nuclear
reactor which is crazy that is happening
there because there's a finite
probability for this to happen so the
Oakland actual reactor is our best
handle on the values of the constants of
nature a few billion years ago when this
event happened you can actually go there
and you get the debris and you know how
many isotopes of different isotopes came
out of this phenomenon this is basically
a reactor going critical and you can
actually get very very accurate very
high precision bounds on the variation
in the constants of nature so every time
I come up with the theory the varying
constants I have to look first thing at
the Oakland a chiral reactor and and the
next thing many other things is
basically a list of constraints you have
to satisfy before you can propose
varying constants
oh that will react very very what me
neither Constance so is everything
except gravity the gravitational
constant doesn't appear there but all
the constants appearing in like nuclear
physics and firm is constant yet you
know all these things and they are there
so so and if you want to go to the
gravitational constant that's more
complicated and the first person to look
at that was actually decays it would be
looked at the way the way the various
plates of the earth are moving or moved
in the past as geological data and if
the gravitational constant was different
then of course you don't move
differently and you can get constraints
from that the gravitational constant is
much more tricky actually to to pin down
someone is making me okay I have to shut
up
one more question
okay who's gonna be a lucky one don't be
shy okay
so I did not write this book to make a
case for this theory whenever I want to
make a case for this theory I write
scientific paper okay so this is a book
for general public general audience most
of it is there as well as what I call
you know the dirty laundry which so it
is there okay
[Applause]
joelma gay zoo is a professor of
theoretical physics at Imperial College
in London faster than the speed of light
is published by Perseus on the web at
Perseus publishing com
[Music]